Mày hai mày tạm tăng xấu hàng in người biểu tình đã tập trung tại Trung tâm trụ đối bằng cơ.
Nhanh phản đấu thủ tướng về trong thân sinh nào quá trang.
Chúng quả cảnh chân chắc biệt giới với cảm gùi chia với nhiều lón ngày về chủ quyền của sang.
Cô biểu tình gió phòng chào lên mình sức mạnh viết nhất nước.
Bảo vệ chủ quyền tổ chức.
Thủ ngử dân từ như tỉnh thành.
Đây là của biểu tình quy mô lớn nhất kể từ khi đảng viết nước thái lên ngắm quyền.
Vào năm nay nền công trong ai người ba.
Cảnh sát chín khai lực lượng đông đào và thích bị giám sát.
Nhân bảo đảm anh đi chật tự, đồng thời thu dưới một số vật giống quyền từ người dân.
Về phía chính phủ thủ tướng thái lan phía thông thàn cho biết,
bà tôn trọng quyền biểu tình và sẵn sản lối thở ở ngoài bình.
Tuy nhiên, bà đang lối mạng người ác lực ra vang khi đảng từ hào thái lan dút hỏi đến mình
và một số hị sĩ đề nghị nếu chang phát ngôn gây chính cãi.
Chông của định đà mới chủ tỉnh thử viện các buc chiếm 1 xanh.
Phía các buc chiếm công khai chỉ trích bà về thông thàn cho khi thái lan khẳng định ưb biên giải phán hỏi ra.
Rồi quan sát cạnh bảo, đồng trích trị giao sài có thể cảm trở nú lượng thu hồi kinh tệ của thái lan trong thời giao tự giá tới.